What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity
This week's table set-up is T Pong
It's gonna be Miikka against me and Otto
Let's go!
And let's get this channel to 2 million
so remember to subscribe!
Only backhand punch
First half of the ball it was only Emil
and then Otto started ripping backhands
Easy miss
No matter what table set-up it is
you still manage to
get me to run a marathon!
Why are you laughing!?
I was a bit left outside of the rally
What?
That's legal you can do that!
Okay okay!
Come on Emil!
Too easy!
Nice movement Otto!
I just couldn't take it seriously anymore!
We need a...
We need a slow motion on that
Please show it again Otto!
Well I was thinking if the ball is short,
I could've rolled on the table and taken it like that
Nice roller!
That's a good strategy
I didn't see that, thanks!
I think we played together pretty well
I think so too, maybe I took over a few times
but at least we had a lot of fun!
I think I had the most fun here but anyway,
remember to subscribe and watch our previous videos
Until next time!